all right people it is 11 a.m eastern on
february 2nd 2022 i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message we are
streaming live on rumble youtube and
blaze tv do me a favor and subscribe
wherever you're most comfortable
watching would you do that for me
and yes it is 11 a.m eastern and it
really hit me this morning that 11 a.m
eastern is a very special time because
you could either be watching the reuben
report you could either be watching dave
rubin try to calmly give you the news
with a little bit of a smile and with
some humor
and a
relatively objective
position on things but obviously
admitting where my biases are or you
could be watching the view and that is a
crazy program that a lot of middle-aged
women are watching right at this very
minute
and i was thinking about it this morning
and i was discussing with my guys it's
like think how fundamentally forget how
different
the reuben report is than the view think
how different the viewers are there are
women it's mostly women there's a couple
gay guys and some women that are
watching the view right now right
they're watching and they're i don't
know what's going on right now because
they suspended whoopi we'll get to that
in a second uh but they're watching that
thing and that's like where they're
getting some of their info and then they
go out there in the real world and they
transmit that information to other
people then you get these brainwashed
zombie npc people
or you guys who are good
no you're great people good looking
people happy people well adjusted people
and people ready to take on the machine
and that's what we're all about here so
we got four stories for you first we're
going all in on this canadian trucker
thing i mean this story is just
incredible it's getting more incredible
by the minute the ridiculous buffoon
that is the prime minister of canada
justin trudeau he put out a tweet and
yes he's blaming the racists so we'll
get to that uh then
vaccine policies for kids they're still
pushing this nonsense this
anti-scientific lunacy we'll talk a
little bit about that then of course the
machine as you know is just still going
all in on trying to take out joe rogan
because joe rogan is actually a threat
to the machine itself so mr potato head
brian stelter was going after rogan
jansocki the liar in chief over at the
white house she was on it and then
finally the fourth story we'll talk
about whoopi's suspension which got
dropped yesterday she's getting a
two-week fully paid suspension which in
other terms is known as a vacation so
congratulations whoopi uh before we get
to any of that though guys i want to
talk to you about shamany by jenyasel
you know valentine's day is only two
weeks away and our dear friends at
genusl have a special treat that you'll
love with all your heart from now till
valentine's day get the brand new
geniusell anti-aging primer for a
radiant glow and a flawless finish free
with every order of geniuselle's most
popular package using the same goodness
that we all love geniusel's new primer
contains botanical extracts and
antioxidants to deeply hydrate brighten
and complete your finished look don't
take my word for it here's a five star
review from saretta in tacoma washington
this primer is amazing i put it on my
when my skin is dry it gives such an
airbrushed look and makes me not even
want to apply anything else i love that
my face glows right through my
foundation
i'm in love ladies treat yourself and
guys this isn't skin care it's a gift of
luxury for that special lady in your
life visit lovejaniacell.com dave and
enter special promo code dave for 10 off
at check out that's love januselle.com
love g-e-n-u-c
dot com
slash dave lovegeniacell.com
dave and now back to me all right this
trucker story is just incredible there's
just no way to overstate it and i sense
that the way the machine is attacking it
right now is a great sign the more that
they call these people racists and
bigots people who just want to go back
to work who just want to go out to
restaurants who want their kids to go to
school who want to go to church and
temple and wherever else they might go
freely without the intrusiveness of a
government telling them what they can do
and when they can do it so first off
we've showed you a bunch of these videos
already here's a little bit of the video
of the convoy this is in ottawa uh this
is from two days ago but it is still
going on just that strong right now you
know people have been mentioning it
sometimes with wind chill it's like
negative 20 in ottawa it's absolutely
freezing yet these people are out there
they are cheering we showed you videos
yesterday they clean up after themselves
they shovel the streets they're talking
about freedom and liberty and all that
good stuff
although it's not good stuff if you're
the prime minister of canada justin
trudeau he tweeted this out yesterday
today in the house members of parliament
unanimously condemned the anti-semitism
islamophobia anti-black racism
homophobia and transphobia that we've
seen on display in ottawa over the past
number of days together let's keep
working to make canada
more
inclusive
oh my god trudeau you win nonsensical
bingo for the day try to really think
about what these people have been
reduced to you have these people out
there protesting lockdowns protesting
mandates now you may not agree
with them with their position let's say
on lockdowns mandates etc etc you may
have a different position on covid and
policy and everything else but do you
see how the woke mind virus destroys
everything that is good it destroys
logic and reason this fool all he has
left justin trudeau is to call these
people transphobic conor can we pull
that video up again the video in the
snow there i want you to look at these
people i know it's from a distance but
do you think these people are out there
because they hate trans people guys get
out on the streets we hate well actually
phobia the word phobia means an
irrational fear do you think that these
people are out on the streets because
they have an irrational fear of
transphobia of trans people do you see
how nonsensical this is they're afraid
of trans people and they hate jews and
muslims
he's just awful as i mentioned yesterday
jordan peterson said during the show
here in miami on monday night when a
question was asked about canada it's
like justin trudeau cannot say anything
true he is a machine that just repeats
woke talking points and he doesn't even
do it quite well you might remember this
i will never apologize for standing up
for an lgdp l
gt lbg
lgbtq2 plus
kids rights
i mean the
pander
pander in the dictionary should have his
face next to it and if you want his face
next to it well maybe they'd want to
show this picture oh yeah there he is in
blackface there's justin trudeau in
blackface having a good time oh my god
look at him yelling he's having fun
that's not the only time he's been
blackface my god justin trudeau could it
be perhaps justin trudeau that all of
your virtue signaling and calling
everyone else racist is because you're
trying to cover up from your own racist
privileged past you white straight
politician you could that be it justin
trudeau and i was thinking about it it's
like what really is going on with this
guy this person who seems deeply
inauthentic who seems unable to say
a word that is true it's like what is he
he calls everyone else a phobe right
everyone else is in islamophobe and a
transphobe and a you know the rest of it
phobe but it's like he actually is a
freedom of hope that's really what i've
realized here justin trudeau has an
irrational fear of freedom again phobia
is irrational fear he has an irrational
fear that people the citizens in his
country can make choices for themselves
that's what he is that's what he is he
is an anti-liberty
omit
do that work anti-liberty oh might sort
of like an anti-semite he's an
anti-liberty almighty anti-liberty might
something like that that's what he is he
hates freedom he hates the idea that you
can make choices for yourself he thinks
he's the king
and it all comes from a place because he
himself knows that he has the past of
racism he ain't a good guy he ain't a
good guy he ain't a good guy at all but
it's not just him that ain't a good guy
there's this guy trevor noah who's on
comedy central now nobody watches the
daily show anymore everyone knows this
and i think you could probably make an
argument that the only reason
trevor noah even has the gig anymore is
because of identity politics because
they don't want to deal with the
nonsense of firing him but the simple
truth is everyone talked about the show
it was a cultural icon and mainstage
during jon stewart's years they handed
it to this guy now nobody watches it
clips never go viral blah blah blah but
there is this small sliver of media
people that still like it so we saw this
clip and we thought it was worth
throwing in because if you want to see
how it's not just justin trudeau
and other canadian officials that are
slamming these good decent people for
taking control of their lives it's
people like trevor noah who is on comedy
central which is owned by viacom it's a
massive corporate show and here's what
he had to say about those truckers
nazi flags peeing on war memorials
shouting racial slurs in homeless
shelters honestly it's kind of
refreshing to see canadians break their
stereotype although maybe they did all
of this in like a very polite way go
back to where you came from eh
i'll give you a ride if you want i do
kind of feel bad for the vast majority
of the protesters who aren't nazis
though because
like
i mean people let's admit it once a nazi
flag shows up at a rally the whole thing
has just turned into a nazi rally you
know it's like when you put the
cantaloupe in a fruit salad it doesn't
matter what other fruits are in there it
all tastes like cantaloupe now
cantaloupe is the hitler fruits is what
i'm saying
they have probably 20 to 30 writers for
that show did you smile during that did
you think it was funny or clever the
fruit salad reference didn't even really
make sense and
you know if you have a group of people
let's say you have a group of people say
a thousand people and they're all
protesting freedom and one crazy guy
comes in
and has a bad mean flag or a bad flag or
he says something bad or he's waving
some weird stick
does that taint the entire thing
does it
and
would it be possible
just putting it out there would it be
possible
that people who wanted to taint the
entire thing the way that justin uh the
way that uh trevor noah says that it
would taint the entire thing would it be
possible that people who want to taint
the entire thing could set up somebody
to put them there with the bad flag so
the media will focus on that bad flag
and try to taint everybody and maybe
that's why trevor noah is trying to put
that message out there because he's part
of the problem when it comes to that
sort of thing
20 to 30 writers do that guys how many
writers do i have
zero
zero
it is what it is what can i tell you but
anyway they're trying to show you that
these people are transphobes they're
bigots they're nazis and other such bad
things
well here we got some video of some of
these people ladies and gentlemen i'm
down here with a police officer in
ottawa how are you doing today doing
great how's it been down here uh nothing
but good people are super good the
truckers have been uh having a good time
they've been getting their point across
and you know what it's a beautiful city
that we're in and
they can't ignore all of this right
absolutely thank you very much
man
is there anything worse than those types
of people peacefully doing things
everybody's happy we're cleaning up
garbage we're shoveling snow we're
peacefully protesting we're doing
exactly
what you're supposed to do in a free
democracy or as justin trudeau and
trevor noah call it you know a bunch of
nazis bigots and racists i feel that if
today's beginning of the program this
first segment was a uh was a legal
argument i i feel that we can vote to
convict i think that that's what it is
trudeau you gotta go you gotta go man i
don't care if you're hiding in your
bunker and pretending to have covid you
know asymptomatic cobia because your
kid's got and everything else nobody
likes you nobody likes you even the
people that you think like you they
don't like you they're they're just as
pandering and confused as you are but
we're going to keep pushing on this
because i like canada i like canadians i
want people to be free and you're a bad
dude can we get him in blackface one
more time let's just get him in black i
just really want to etch this that is
the man who is saying all of these
things about yeah i'm going to read the
tweet one more time while we show his
face there because i don't think we did
that the first day around here's justin
trudeau's tweet as you look at him
in blackface today in the house members
of parliament unanimously condemn the
anti-semitism islamophobia anti-black
racism homophobia and transphobia that
we've seen on display in ottawa over the
past number of days together let's keep
working to make canada more inclusive
there he is there's your inclusion
people
oh
all right let's move on uh so look i've
been talking about the machine a lot
right like it feels like whatever the
structure is that allows us to have
conversation that allows certain things
to get out there it does feel like it's
in flux in a much bigger way than usual
right there's the rogan story that you
all know about and we're going to get to
more on that in just a second there's
this canadian trucker thing you can you
get this feeling suddenly that the push
back against the machine is gaining
momentum and that is sort of why they're
calling us all of these horrible things
well jake tapper is a democrat he is a
democrat who pushes democrat policies
and is always trying to slam and slander
republicans or conservatives on a show
but he pretends to be a journalist uh
here he is talking about kids and
opening schools and vaccinations and
tell me if what he's doing here is just
reporting straight information or adding
his opinion into it one of the things
that that uh look this show has been
talking about the need to open school
since the summer of 2020 uh so i'm not
against that and we've been talking
because we've been following the science
and that's what the science has been
saying one of the things that's a little
bit frustrating is people demanding
schools be open people demanding that
the students don't have to wear masks
without acknowledging that most kids are
still not vaccinated if you want to it
seems to me you want to open the schools
as safely as possible
you know all the kids and teachers and
faculty and staff need to be vaccinated
that's the safest thing to do right
right you can't have it both ways you
can't not vaccinate your kids and also
want your kids to go to school
completely unencumbered
uh you know right now if you're looking
at children in the united states less
than as you said less than half of
children who are eligible for vaccines
are vaccinated and remember no child
under the age of five in this country is
vaccinated
uh you know last last week there were
two million uh uh cases in kids yeah
did jay tapper just report that straight
or did you did he tell you what his
opinion about vaccinating children is
i'll leave that for you to decide he
said that his show has been following
the science and since june of 2020
they've been telling people to open
schools now jake i don't know if you're
watching this but i would love to know
what study you're referring to that
suddenly said schools could open in june
of 2020. there were plenty of people
saying that we should have never closed
schools there was plenty of information
very very early on almost immediately
that the recovery rate for children was
something like 99.97
and that also included if they were the
ones that were getting sick actually
really sick
were had all sorts of other
comorbidities and other situations
involved so i don't know exactly what
he's talking about but he follows the
science but then you know he leads it so
the whole thing that they do is they
don't outwardly exactly say what they're
doing but then he's sort of like but you
know i i would pretty much say that you
know these kids aren't vast and if these
kids aren't facts wouldn't it be the
best thing to get these kid back kids
facts then the former fda chief there he
makes note that you know no kid under
five is vast um and that these young
kids who are vast it's like well why
can't they go to school
have we had school outbreaks where
there's suddenly thousands and thousands
of dead kids we haven't fortunately
thankfully there's something known as
natural immunity but the entire machine
has pushed vaccines on us to the point
that no one can make sense of any of
this stuff and believe it or not guys
it's still moving this is why i always
say you have to give the machine credit
no matter how much we push back no
matter how much evidence we show to
expose the nonsense
it keeps pushing so we've got some info
from the daily wire here on what they
want to do now with kids a new report
states that the biden administration's
food and drug administration is pushing
pfizer and its partner bio and tech to
request emergency youth use
authorization for a vaccine for children
as young as six months
pfizer and its partner bioentech the
manufacturers of the vaccine are
expected to submit to the food and drug
administration as early as tuesday a
request for emergency youth use
authorization for the vaccine for
children 6 months to 5 years old which
would make it the first vaccine
available for that age group last friday
pfizer discussed updated trial data with
dr anthony fauci among other government
officials one administration official
told the post of a robust conversation
that three doses were likely more
effective than two shots adding but to
get to that three you have to get two
shots first there's interest in seeing
this move forward according to the covid
project the number of deaths from covet
19 per million population among young
children in the first year of life was
tiny between 1 and 1
sorry going a little too fast there for
me well you can read it right there for
yourself uh
it's basically absolutely tiny and
between two and three years of age 3.3
between three and four years of age and
3.5 between ages 4 and 5.
you get the point here without even
getting lost in the numbers and you guys
can go back and and read that for
yourself the covet has basically not
affected children at all why
would you want the government to give
emergency authorization to a
pharmaceutical company to inject your
six-month-old with this vaccine
if you are a parent i
literally
don't understand i genuinely
don't understand after these people have
been exposed as liars all along masks
work masks don't work you touch your
face more it doesn't do anything anyway
because of the little air pockets blah
blah blah fauci's emails telling his
friends to go on vacation and don't
worry about masks because they don't
work while he's telling us to double
mask
if you get the vaccine you won't get
cobit or transmit it that's what they
told us that's what biden told us that's
what cdc director wolensky told us
turned out not to be true why would you
be okay with the idea that the
government at this point
two years later
would get emergency access to a
pharmaceutical company would give
emergency access to a pharmaceutical
company that has been proven to either
have a faulty product or have lied about
it the entire time and yet millions of
parents are still going to do it
millions of parents are still going to
do it i'm not a parent yet but i cannot
imagine
i genuinely cannot imagine
bringing my six month old child to the
doctor and being like yes inject them
with that stuff
that stuff from the people who lied
about everything all along oh the
government said they could push it
through real fast emergency
yeah injected in the kid let me get
three more okay could you get that for
me i think you get the point there guys
uh all right but this all
sort of fits together right we talk
about the truckers we talk about
pushbacks on vaccines and that the
machine keeps coming and then this is
sort of couched in what the other big
story of the week was this whole week
and started a little bit last week
actually which is that the machine is
moving on joe rogan right there is this
push spotify is going to put
warnings before joe rogan's programs
because he spreads misinformation and
people are calling him a bigot and he
puts all these scary people online but
what this really is about is that cnn
and mainstream media the new york times
and washington post and everything else
they're losing control of the narrative
they know that rogan's audience
dwarfs them it's not even close stelter
gets maybe a couple hundred thousand
people and that includes all the people
at the airports and all the people who
are just passively watching or have the
tv on nobody's really watching this like
think about it this way like does anyone
really care about brian stelter right if
he didn't have the chair on the sunday
morning show reliable sources which i
always tell you is the most ironically
named show in television history should
be called unreliable sources and then it
would make a little sense uh if he
didn't have that chair right if they
fired him from that show stelter has no
audience he has no people that would
subscribe to him or watch him or
anything else but the machine puts these
sort of half-baked people in they do
their shows it seems like oh my god he's
on a show called reliable sources and
that's on cnn and it seems very
well the point is that they're losing
control
rogan is bigger than them and they don't
know what to do so stelter is very
concerned about that the narrative is i
want to show all kinds of opinions
which sounds great but not all opinions
are created equal you think about major
newsrooms like cnn that have health
departments and deaths and operations
that work hard on verified information
october 19. and then you have talk show
stars like joe rogan who just wing it
who make it up as they go along and
because figures like rogan are trusted
by people that don't trust real news
rooms we have attention a problem that's
much bigger than spotify much bigger
than any single platform kate but that's
what the heart of this right now yeah
but you're right it is getting at
something bigger that isn't going to be
solved in one joe rogan video or
why should we trust you mr potatohead
why should we trust you at this point
you lied about donald trump very fine
people on both sides you lied about
brett kavanaugh being a serial rapist
you lied about the covington kids being
racist you lied about russia collusion
you lied about jesse smallette the list
goes on and on you hid
the hunter biden story while you went
bananas when donald trump jr had lunch
with someone for five minutes on the
upper east side five years ago you
people lie about everything and just
because you have a big newsroom that
means that doesn't mean that that big
newsroom is doing something good that
means that you've got an awful lot of
liars carefully curating the nonsense
that you're pushing out to people but of
course it's not just you brian stelter
much of this comes directly from the
administration and you guys know how
much i like talking about jen saki so
we've got a jen sake video and you know
because everyone these days is putting
warnings content warnings out on stuff
we thought guys maybe we should put a
content warning every time we show a
video from saki because she's always
lying and spreading misinformation and
disinformation there you go content
advisory warning what you're about to
see
is [ __ ] take a look last week the
surgeon general also was asked on msnbc
about joe rogan's vaccine comments
on spotify and he said that tech
companies have an important role to play
in stopping misinformation because the
uh they are the predominant places where
misinformation spreads does the white
house and the administration think this
is a satisfactory step our hope is that
all major tech platforms and all major
news sources for that matter be
responsible and be vigilant to ensure
the american people have access to
accurate information on something as
significant as covid19 that certainly
includes spotify so this disclaimer it's
a positive step but we want every
platform to continue doing more to call
out misinformed miss and disinformation
while also uplifting accurate
information
oh jen
oh jen
i don't like you jen but i'm trying to
be nice this morning um first off
nobody should care what the white house
thinks
about what a private company does okay
it's irrelevant well it should be
irrelevant
and this is how they push this is how
they get as close as they can to
violating the first amendment without
quite violating the first amendment and
you all know about this right we had the
surgeon general who came out and said
you know that the government should look
into a little bit more we should kind of
be thinking about misinformation when it
comes to joe rogan's podcast it's like
we're not going to pass a law saying he
can't say stuff but we're going to just
think about it and then and then think
about it this way you're joe rogan right
you're sitting at home you're joe rogan
you're eating your elk you're working
out you're doing your thing you're
sitting there with the scary wolf all of
the stuff and then you open up twitter
and you see that the surgeon general is
thinking about you and you might just as
an individual you might go ah maybe i
won't do that stuff so there's a certain
pressure that they can apply that is as
close to violating the first amendment
as they possibly could and we know of
course we've shown you the video many
times a few months back where saki said
that the white house flags posts for
facebook so if you're the guy at
facebook and you're sitting there at
your desk
and you're doing your thing and you're
good and you're a diversity hire and
you're just a nice diversity hire and
you're trans and you're black and you're
you have one eye and whatever it is but
you're a good worker uh you know and all
that stuff and then you get a message
from the white house and they say uh you
know we'd really like you to flag this
thing well you're gonna do it because
you're a good diversity hire and you're
gonna do what you're told because that's
what a good american citizen does
this would be an instance of a company
in this case facebook's a public company
but getting pressure from the government
to impede on speech we got a big problem
here
so what are we going to do about this
problem i think we just got to keep
pushing we all got to find our inner
canadian truck driver right now uh
because saki rogan's allowed to talk
about what he wants to talk about and
stelter just because you got a big news
room doesn't mean it's doing anything
good and uh i got nothing better to do
than stop you guys so we're just gonna
keep moving on that uh the final story
for today is an extension of something
we've been talking about the last couple
days
whoopi goldberg
goldberg
goldberg has been suspended by abc
because of some comments that she made
about holocaust the holocaust and the
jews
goldberg
goldberg got some info from the
associated press whoopi goldberg was
suspended for two weeks tuesday as
co-host of the view because of what the
head of abc news called her wrong and
hurtful comments about jews and the
holocaust while whoopi has apologized
i've asked her to take time to reflect
and learn about the impact of her
comments the entire abc news
organization stands in solidarity with
our jewish colleagues friends and family
and communities abc news president kim
godwin said in a statement my words
upset so many people which was never my
intention she said tuesday morning i
understand why now
and for that i am deeply deeply grateful
because the information i got was really
helpful and helped me understand
some different things so first i just
want to reiterate something that i said
yesterday which is that i do not think
that uh whoopi goldberg
who chose her name
chose her name her stage name whoopi
goldberg her real name is i said karen
walker yesterday but it's not karen
walker it's
karen johnson
uh she chose her stage name because she
was actually very influenced by a lot of
jewish people when she was growing up
okay so it was an homage to these people
i don't think she's an anti-semite i
don't think she hates jews i think she's
very confused about what the nazis were
all about that they viewed jews as
another race
by the way judaism because it's a
religion and an ethnicity and a culture
we can talk about all of that stuff
related to race the problem here is that
because she's gone so in on the woke
ideology that puts skin color above
everything else she's having trouble
seeing that and she's just in over her
head but i but i don't think she hates
jews number one
and i don't think actually that
suspending her now she got suspended for
two weeks paid so she's gonna make money
and sit at home and eat bon bons and
enjoy herself um but i don't think
suspending her is the right idea right
if we're gonna if we're gonna stand up
against cancel culture if we're going to
really try to work through these issues
honestly then what really makes sense
here like what is suspending her for two
weeks actually do like if anything she's
probably a little more annoyed you've
enraged some people who are trying to
understand the nuance of the issue but
why not have her on the show today and
have someone honestly have a
say a holocaust historian or a
sociologist
on the show to explain some of that
stuff i mean if you think this is
important to talk about right if abc
thinks this is so important that we
should spend her for saying what she
thinks however misguided why not use
this time when the when the magnifying
glass is on it right why not use it so
that you can educate her thus educating
other people but we do this very odd
thing no she must be removed from
society for two weeks and paid
i don't care about the paid or unpaid
but it just feels like nonsense and also
it's like you have to understand that
there's a there's a theater and a show
business version of this it's like if
you were whatever you do for a living
whatever you do for a living let's say
you're an accountant
right you're an accountant and you're in
an office of accountants and let's say
one of you the other accountants you
guys are by the water cooler do we have
water coolers anymore i'm not sure but
buy the coffee machine i think we have
those still you buy the coffee machine
and one of the
accountants says something about the
holocaust that doesn't ring true and
then the other account and brings that
to hr and then hr's answer is you
accountant you will not crunch numbers
for the next two weeks you will go home
and you will get paid to do nothing for
two weeks and then you can come back to
work and everything's okay it's like
none of this really makes any sense
these these slap on the wrists odd
things but the unfortunate part here
really is that there was a teachable
moment and we sort of just went by that
teachable moment uh fortunately though i
know that you guys don't watch the view
except when i show you clips of it and i
apologize because the view is on right
now and you're watching this
you're not watching the view
i feel this was a very full show how do
we how do we feel about the show today
guys
i got i got three thumbs up i got thumbs
up on everything yeah uh all right i
think we got a couple do we have some
locals comments we're gonna throw in
today uh guys my full interview while we
grab those my full interview with glenn
beck who has a new book all about the
great reset and glenn has been warning
about all of this stuff forever and the
book by the way
beyond crushed it in sales they sold out
of the original print
immediately
new york times totally screwed him you
know it's so funny what the new york
times does and it just tells you if they
lie about numbers like what else did
they lie about new york times i mean
book sales are about numbers and and
they they're very easily trackable sales
are easily trackable right
uh the new york times put him i think at
number 12
which so he made the list but he should
have i think been number one or number
two probably number one uh and
it's like they just if they're gonna lie
about that guys what else are they gonna
lie about that whoa brad is telling me
that cnn uh ceo jeff zucker has just
resigned is that true
holy [ __ ]
we're winning guys do you get it yet
we're actually winning the thing is
crumbling and we're going to have an
incredible opportunity now that is
incredible news is it too early for the
tequila is it wow hot damn
oh it was announced 15 minutes ago over
an inappropriate work place relationship
oh lord lordy lordy did he say something
dirty to stealther who knows uh here's a
memo from zucker that's just coming out
i'm just reading this on the fly guys as
part of the investigation into chris
cuomo's tenure at cnn i was asked about
a consensual relationship with my
closest colleague someone i have worked
with for more than 20 years i
acknowledge the relationship the
relationship evolved in recent years i
was required to disclose it when it
began but i didn't i was wrong and as a
result i am resigning today
all right it sounds like we don't know
who the colleague is it doesn't sound
like this involves sexual harassment or
rape or whatever maybe this is a little
bit of a technicality look again these
things where it's like we're all human
beings we all have relationships we've
all made mistakes we've all done stupid
things in our past i can't believe i'm
not even defending jeff zucker and i
obviously need to know more about this
and i think jeff zucker stepping down is
good because he's led putting aside
whatever happened here he's led cnn down
a really really horrible path um where
they no longer are journalism and they
were something roughly approximating
journalism for a long time so it's
probably good that he's stepping down in
the name of journalism or at least for
the sake of journalism um but this thing
where it's like we're all gonna look
into everybody's past and you made a
pass at somebody at a bar way back when
and you said that thing about that
person and you did
that thing it's like man unless we all
want to live in glass houses we better
watch out uh as i said guys my full
interview with glenn beck is up on
locals right now absolutely ad free uh
clip one will be up shortly on youtube
and rumble and if you want to play along
we do a live chat during each and every
show uh you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com
and justin trudeau
i'm coming for you man see ya